Alright everybody, welcome to another of our weekly Zoom calls.
This is a great reminder verse, not to be anxious about anything, but take everything
to the Lord in prayer, interesting how Paul writes it, with thanksgiving, present your
request to God.
Sometimes with me it seems to be with why neither complaining, but I need to be checked
on that. So we take things to God in prayer with thanksgiving, with a grateful heart,
thankful that we're alive. Remember that, yes, we want, you know, to be healed or we want
to this or that or whatever from Him. And God knows it before we even ask it, but it's a good
reminder to recall, to have that relationship with Him, to be asking Him things. But doing it with
a grateful heart, a thankful heart, praising Him that He is our sister. And we are only
alive today in this sliver of time that we call our life right now, that we need to stay focused
for better how well our circumstances are on internal perspectives. But in comparison to
eternity on a timeline, it is literally a pinpoint and time of this life that we have on
50, 60, 70, 80, 90 years compared to eternity. We need to be living for eternity.
That's how we can understand and feel and experience a peace of God, which truly transcends all
understanding, and that will guard our hearts and minds in Christ Jesus. So good reminder there,
another reminder, make sure you check our blogs for different things if you're looking for different
things between Zoom calls and our members site. And I always look at our members site for any updates,
we didn't have any updates this week. We also want updates that we didn't really talk about too much
last week because our courses, we have a stop fighting cancer course, which nobody here needs to be on
because you have all that information or most of that information in your members site.
We have a detoxification course, we're launching, we have a line course, so it might be interesting
for those that maybe have line also or have family members with line. That course could be
interesting to people. And then we also will have the right course launched, hopefully by
the end of this week, maybe by the beginning of next week, that will go live. And please do not
buy any other courses. Dustin is once he gets the right course done, he's going to figure out to allow
all our patients, all you listening to this will have free access to those courses. So stop fighting
cancer course. There may be some new information in there that I don't think so, but the detoxification
course definitely do good information in there for all our cancer patients. The line course only
really for people that would have line or family members that have line. And the right course.
So the right course is going to have more, even more information than what's on our right page here.
More, not necessarily information that you need to use, but more information on the right in general
frequencies. But remember, if you haven't looked already on the right page of your of the member site,
I've added a bunch of new videos that were taken as steps of Q&As off the Zoom calls. So
all right, here's the first question. I just had a cholesterol test taken a blood test and my numbers
moved up a total cholesterol has always been high 214 to 280. And jump from 214 to 231 HDL,
state study, LDL, jumped up, triglycerides always find currently 88 and currently
but a low dose of statin to do not want to increase it. Do you have some ideas for me? Well, I can't tell
anybody to take or not to take a statin, but honestly, I'm totally not a fan of statins.
I'm totally not a fan of what is considered normal and therefore high cholesterol either
where I was in school. High cholesterol was considered over 250. Then they dropped it down to 220.
Then they dropped it to 200. Now they dropped it to 180. Why? So that they could sell more
statins. Boy, that's cynical. But honestly, it's true. So what is a normal cholesterol? Well,
the truth is all your normal blood levels are normal for the general population that is very normal
for you. But you're truly concerned with cancer is low cholesterol. So it's common with cancer and
with progression of cancer is when you're cholesterol plumbers to like 120. That's a dangerous
sign. Having high cholesterol is not good, but you want to look at why you have high cholesterol.
Certainly don't have high cholesterol because you have a deficiency in statins. Almost always a person
has increased in cholesterol. When it is clinically, relevantly increased, it's because of some
congestion in the liver. Therefore your body makes more cholesterol. That's where people struggle
with it. Clean up my diet of eating perfectly and my cholesterol didn't really budge. It's because
really only about 3% of your cholesterol, blood cholesterol has any relationship to your diet.
Except that a bad diet can cause congestion in the liver. So if you eat a lot of chemicals,
processed foods, etc. Problem is is that once we end up with fatty liver disease, even when we
clean up our diet and do a lot of really good things like detoxification, it doesn't necessarily
clean up the fatty liver disease. That still exists. So that is a major issue with cholesterol.
Personally, I don't worry about cholesterol until it's over 300, 320. And then you start doing some
things, but there's certainly multiple nutritional things that you can do for high cholesterol.
Off the top of the head, burberry, it can be good for high cholesterol. And let's see.
I'm glad that we had from orthobacteria. That was good for cholesterol.
I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I have to think of it. I don't remember it.
As we go through this, I don't know. Let's talk to that again.
So, I think you get back to my screen. I do two things at once. I don't know which is my screen.
Secondly, my hemoglobin A1C was at 5.6,
that he higher had to be considered pre-diabetic. This was alarming to me as I've never been
overweight, no, or had a thought of diabetes. I did a little homework and found that high levels of
vitamin C and E and Z, plus high cholesterol can elevate hemoglobin A1C. I'm wondering if I should
adjust by supplements? No, I wouldn't. You're taking vitamin C, E and Z to stimulate
in immune response. You don't want to decrease that to get your hemoglobin A1C down.
I would want to look at other things that we have going on with your diet first,
before I would do that. Yes, I don't know who asked this question, so maybe
set up a time to talk about that specifically. Next question. Can you elaborate on the directions
for the radiation when we have panic drops and the weekly foot baths for radiation? I finished the
101 minimum full brain radiate, oh, 10, what a minute full brain radiation treatments last week.
I did one of each foot baths. The first heavy metal one turned out a ton of rusty looking stuff
and made my feet achy. The second one was clear and my feet felt normal. There isn't a way
to measure the degree of toxicity from radiation in one's body. You can't measure it. You have to
make some assumptions. When you have radiation as far as a treatment, like radiation for a tumor
or a radiation for a cancer in the brain, you're getting a huge dose of radiation. What is lethal
to the cancer cells in damaging to healthy cells? Now, it may be the appropriate thing to do,
but you're getting a lot of radiation. You're really just doing that literally,
if you only have one session of it, you should probably be on a regular radiation detox
for a long, long time. Let me talk in years. You do 10 sessions or 30 sessions of radiation. You should
just think of that you're always going to be supporting your body to help you detox radiation.
Using the radiation, as it is listed on the label, I would just stick to that. It doesn't mean you take
more of it. It just means you're going to take it longer and continuing to do detox, foot baths,
on a fairly regular basis. Once you do radiation, maybe you're doing them every day. Maybe you're
doing them at least three times a week. You're trying to do it on a regular basis to help your body detox.
There's no such thing as I'm completely detoxed. You're never completely detoxed because you're always
toxifying yourself. Maybe you're not getting further radiation. A lot of people take the radiation
drops because they had x-rays. Good as x-rays. The difference in rad dose from an x-ray or a CT scan
compared to radiation therapy is astronomical. You're really radiation therapy. You really get a
huge dose of rad and you want to think about your continuing to detox at a regular basis.
Back to this question, I knew I would think of it. The product that you use for cholesterol is
bergamot. Bergamot. Bergamot has been shown B-E-R-G-A-M-O-T. We have a product called
product called bergamot that can be extremely beneficial for reducing cholesterol. That's a
design for health product. Think about using something like that, completely not toxic, like
statnis, and you can help with cleaning out your liver. Also, other things that you do to clean
out your liver, like your cholesterol packs and your coffee enemas. Again, the reason why you do it
is to help your body with detoxification, help your body, your liver get cleaned out.
But remember, if you have fatty liver disease, which is so common, probably everybody has some degree of it,
you may never get those down to what the medical profession considers normal levels.
Next question is part of my continued effort to stay in remission. From a very cancer,
I've decided to have my mercury fillings removed. Good idea. Unfortunately, I have several of them.
Yeah, most people do. I saw a biological dentist today. In a short view, they were happy to hear
I was working with cutters. Clinic can ask me to ask you if there's anything they need to know about
my treatment before start removing them replacing the silver fillings. So when you have the
your mercury fillings removed, you want to do what this person is doing. You want to go to a biological
dentist to do that, because they will use a mercury vapor vacuum. They will mask you. They will
do different suction techniques, and they will use a rubber dam so that they're not spilling any.
When they're drilling it out, they're gasifying the mercury. That's the most damaging part. If you're
breathing that in, you're just poisoning yourself. But getting that out is super, super important.
Now, we don't recommend people getting their silver fillings removed when they're in the
throes of cancer, because then you're having to deal with detoxifying the mercury at the same time.
So once you're in this point, I feel like in a relative state of remission, maybe it's time to work
on these other things. That's what this person is doing. So what else should you do? So when you know
you're going to go and get your mercury fillings out, a couple of things. So you want to be adding
binders. So if you have not looked at the seven phases of detoxification,
information. The course is one thing. That's a good thing to look at. But remember, I don't have
you, I don't have a way to give you access to that course. But let me pull up a blog post because I did
a blog post summary of my book, the seven phases of detoxification. So let me get to that and I'll show you
what that is. And I made a video on it. So here's the blog post. And just all you have to do is go to
the blog section right there. Look, just start typing in detoxification or the seven phases of detoxification.
There's multiple blog posts on that. What I want you to look at is you need to be binding stuff
in the gut. So you need to make sure that phase six that you're eliminating properly in a regular
basis. Yes, I am. Are you doing copy animals? Yes, I am. Great. So that will help with phase one and
two and three that will help with phase six. Phase five of detoxification is binding stuff in the gut.
So you want to make sure that you're taking a binder. So in that, I list on that blog post, I list some
really good binders. And then you want to make sure that then that you're also starting to use
a key later. Now, if you have seven mercury fillings that they're going to take out over the course
of six months, then it's a little bit more difficult to recommend that key later right away because
if you're going to take a long time of getting these out, we don't want to use a key later
to pull that is pulling stuff out of the fillings that are remaining in your mouth.
But still, I would recommend what's called phase a zero assist. Phase zero assist is I think the
better of all our binders, we also have Kila clear. That's a great binder. One of those two, excuse me,
both of those are key laders. Those are both good key laders to take. You only need one of those.
So touch base with us so we can make some recommendations for you specifically because I don't
know who it is that's asking this question. So when you're going to get your fillings out,
want to make sure that all your phases of detoxification are open. So if you do have no idea what I'm
talking about, go back to the blog, look up phases of detoxification. There's multiple blog posts on it,
several of them have my video that explained the seven phases of detoxification. You can download the seven
phases of detoxification book, at least part of the book on our website for free. And soon I'll give
everybody that are my patients access to the seven phases of detoxification course that goes through
that. But when you're detoxing heavy metals because you're going to liberate them through
upholding them out of the body with a biological dentist, you want to make sure you're binding them
in the gut, so you're not reabsorbing them, and that you're key lading them out of the blood,
so you're getting them out of the blood so they're not just transferring to another cell.
Next question. And I mentioned that the use of benzo was a cancer
balancer in my situation. Can you please explain what a cancer balancer means?
Thanks so much. So we can't legally say this is a cancer treatment. We can't legally say this is a
cancer killer. We can't say this is a cancer natural chemo therapy. We can't use those terminology.
So we just came up with the terminology cancer balancer. We think that's going to be
up things. So if I bend this all, technically can help your body kill cancer. But we can't say that.
So we use the term cancer balancer. So we say cancer balancer. That's what we mean. We're just
keeping ourselves safe. Can you explain what nitric oxide is? My conventional doctor recommended me to
take two capsules per day. Is this okay to take with the rest of my supplements?
No. So let's talk about that. So nitric oxide is a nutrient that is typically prescribed
by functional medicine doctors and naturopaths and things. To it stimulates a certain receptor of the
smooth muscles that lie in the arteries. So there's the arteries are lied by an epithelial cell,
single cell epithelial cell called anothelial cells. And under that there's a layer of smooth
muscles. Now the smooth muscles are intermated, meaning the neurological connection to the smooth
muscles is the autonomic nervous system. Remember the autonomic nervous system separates into two
components, the sympathetic and the parasympathetics. So if there's a sympathetic situation,
meaning a police car pulls up behind you and turns out in sirens, you feel like your blood pressure
goes up. Why? Because your sympathetic kick-in, what your sympathetic do is they contract,
cause those smooth muscles underneath the endothelial cells to contract. Why? Because there's a crisis
situation and when those contract your vessels get smaller, it makes the blood go through them faster
because it needs to shut blood to the extremities so you can run away. That's what a sympathetic
response does, does other things too, but that's what it does to the blood vessels. So it causes
an increased blood pressure. So if a person has an increased blood pressure and they're dealing,
that's what they're dealing with, it's a hyper blood pressure, so they have a high blood pressure
situation. Nitric oxide would be a help for that. So nitric oxide helps to, it goes and attaches to
the certain receptor, uh, no smooth muscles called the endotensin-2 receptor and it causes that
muscle to relax. That's what nitric oxide does to the smooth muscles. Causes that smooth muscle
to relax. Nitric oxide also stimulates another pathway to it. So first of all, let me finish that
discussion. So the number one reason why a person would choose nitric oxide as a supplement,
the number one reason is to decrease blood pressure. Number two reason is to, it is to, is for a
erectile dysfunction. It can be very helpful for that because if you can open up the blood vessels,
you're going to get an increased blood flow to an area. We need a better quality blood flow to the
area, more oxygenation to the area. The problem with nitric oxide and cancer is that nitric oxide
also stimulates a whole other pathway called your Vege F pathway, your vascular endothelial growth
factor. Well, that's really good to stimulate Vege F if your problem is high blood pressure
because you might have actually some damage to blood vessels if you've had high blood pressure
for a long period of time. Therefore, Vege F would be very beneficial. Vascular endothelial growth
factor would be beneficial in that case because we want to grow more blood vessels because that's
what vascular endothelial growth factor does. It helps stimulate the growth of new capillaries.
So we want to stimulate the growth of new capillaries, especially around my heart. So if I have
heart issues, blood pressure issues, then the taking nitric oxide is one of the best things for you.
It's a great product. And if a person does not have cancer, but has blood pressure issues,
or let's say it doesn't have cancer, but doesn't even have blood pressure, but has heart issues
in the family. Taking some nitric oxide can be very important. We actually look at
person genetics. And if they don't have cancer, we may recommend nitric oxide based upon their
genetics because that's a whole other gene pathway. Genetic pathway is how you make nitric oxide
and it connects with vascular endothelial growth factor. The problem, though, if a person has a
diagnosis of cancer, is that we do not want to stimulate vascular endothelial growth factor because
that will help stimulate the growth of new capillaries into a cancer. There is a boatload of research
on trying to find drugs that will stop VEGF, that will block VEGF in cancer patients. So I would
not recommend a cancer patient taking nitric oxide. Why? Because it stimulates VEGF, and you don't
want VEGF stimulated with cancer. So that's what you could go back to your doctor and say,
yeah, I've been doing some research and I don't think I want to take nitric oxide because it stimulates
VEGF vascular endothelial growth factor, and that's not what you're supposed to stimulate when you have
cancer. And there is a boatload of research on that. You could just google it. So I take note of that.
I tried to use the ionic foot bath, the ion pro wave, and the device that goes into the water wasn't
lighted up when placed in the water. When I pulled it out, the blue light would come on. So, okay,
this is not a problem with the ion pro wave. It's a problem with the computer. So if you have a problem
with your ion pro wave, something similar to this, the ion goes on. I took the water, it goes off,
I take it out, it goes on again. It is a Microsoft update issue. So you don't want to run the Microsoft
updates. You should not have your computer connected to the internet. Make sure that your computer
is on airplane mode. So it's not trying to run Microsoft updates. But the solution to this is that you
boot the computer down. And you do what's called a hard boot of your computer. Meaning go to the
power button on your computer. Hold it down for 10 seconds until the computer completely turns off.
Wait about five minutes, then come back. Now we turn the button, push the button on again,
allow it to do a full reboot. That should fix the problem. If you have problems with it,
after that, they make sure you call mic it through right. And there could be, could be something,
there always could be something wrong. But that is 99 out of 100 times. It's a Microsoft issue.
So we just need to do a reboot of the computer. Okay, some questions that came in.
What is in protein powder that you don't have that you don't
it to have in don't like to have in it. Okay, so what is it in protein powder that you want to have
a minimum of? And that is glutamine. So glutamine is an amino acid. So protein powder by definition
is going to have amino acids in it. That's what a protein powder is has amino acids in it. So there's
different concentrations of different amino acids depending on the type of protein powder.
Some protein powders are made are formulated with the idea to help heal the gut.
So some protein powders are formulated with different ideas, different conditions of mic.
Many of the protein powders out there are formulated with the idea to help heal the gut.
Well, glutamine is an amino acid, which is really good to help heal the gut.
Well, why does glutamine help heal the gut? Because glutamine works better than most
amino acids to help stimulate growth. So when you're talking about
healing gut cells, you want, you know, rapid growth. So they go turn over and you'll get a new
gut cell growing and it will be healthy and you're going to help heal the gut. Well, you don't want
to use glutamine or you're going to get glutamine in your diet because it's in all proteins.
You're eating any proteins even plant proteins will still have glutamine, but you don't want to take
a product that has a whole bunch of glutamine because you don't want to stimulate a bunch of growth.
So you don't use protein powders. If you have cancer, you don't use protein powders that have
a lot of glutamine in it. Usually, it's fairly easy to see a lot of protein powders don't show
the exact concentration of each amino acid, some say a mix. So it's a little bit harder to see.
Sometimes you have to go on the company's website to see, you know, what the concentration of
the amino acids are, but you want something that's relatively lower in glutamine or doesn't have
excess glutamine compared to the other amino acids. That's the biggest thing. So you want one that's not
was not formulated with healing the gut in mind. Next question is there a website? You suggest that we
should look to find a good biological dentist in our area. No, no, there may be a website that
biological dentist subscribe to, but I would bet that not all biological dentist subscribe to such
website. So I would look just Google biological dentist near me, and then you can contact them.
If they have a website, then you could look at their website and see, like if they say safe mercury
removal, safe mercury filling removal, and then they go into some detail how they do that,
like they're using a mercury vacuum, etc. Then you could feel pretty rest assured that you're going
to somebody who knows what they're doing. And I guess that's what I would look for. I don't think
that there's a website for that. Maybe, and I don't think so. Next, my blood test showed the
eocidophils lymphocytes, monocytes, and others are lower compared to blood test in May. Is this
because I stopped rapid immune boost? These have to do with my immune system. Yes, those are different
immune cells. They can fluctuate up and down due to exposure of different things. Typically,
if you're exposed to little allergens, your eocidophils will be higher. If you're using different things
to stimulate your immune system like rapid immune boost, then all those can be a little bit higher.
If as long as they're still within normal range, I wouldn't be concerned about them. I've
going to a state for three months where cannabis is legal. At the dispensary, I had no idea what to
purchase. What would you recommend for extreme pain? I stopped morphing because it didn't stop the
pain. It caused nausea and constipation. The Tylenol and ibuprofen don't stop the pain either.
If you're going to use some sort of cannabis for pain, you really have to go to THC.
The CBD can help with some pain, can help with some anxiety around pain,
especially if you're taking a fairly high dose. I spoke to somebody in the phone the other day
that one of their issues was pain and they were taking like 15 milligrams of CBD. I'm sorry,
I didn't get anything. That's not even enough to help with anxiety or help with sleep or anything.
You need to be taking a much higher dose than that. That's CBD. The THC
I would talk to the person at the dispensary about your condition and let them
make a recommendation on the dose of THC. I've not been to a dispensary ever, so I don't know how
things are labeled as far as milligram dose. I think with THC, most of it will start with like a
5 milligrams dose and move up from there. The thing is whatever you're taking, whether it be a gummy
or a product that is like a paste, it will stay longer in your system if you take it with a fat.
So typically, in a lot of the dispensaries, you will get THC and you can buy it in a gummy.
That makes it nice and easy to take because it's in like a little sugar, you know, sweet,
tasty gummy because THC kind of has an ashered taste to it. It's a little more expensive that way
but sometimes people like taking it that way better, but that's in a sugar solution. It will,
you'll get a spike of THC and then it will dissipate quite quickly. If you take it with a fat,
meaning you could even like, you know, take it with some peanut butter or a big tablespoon of
coconut oil, it's going to dissipate much slower, much more slowly and it will stay in your system
longer. I'm more in favor of using the dropper bottles of THC. It doesn't have a great
flavor, but if you could just deal with that and you could chase it with something pretty easy
and you want to make sure you, if you take it on an empty stomach again, it's going to, you know,
spike and it might help with the pain but it will disappear real quick. If you take it on a full
stomach where you've had some fat to eat, it will work more slowly. Then the nice thing about the
dropper is that you can play with your dose and see what you need. Lots of times with pain, you need to
just break that pain cycle and then you can kind of stay on top of it. So you're going to have to play
with the dose of how much you'll need. The nice thing with a dropper, it's going to be less expensive
than getting it in a gummy form and it's going to be easier for you to play with your dose that way.
I get frequent shooting pains in Prometheus, my cancer, cancer stack tumor, probably four times
daily. Each time I have this pain, I get between one to six sharp pains. Some have stopped me
from moving. You know why I'm having these pains? Usually when you get like stabbing, shooting
pains from the cancer, so pain has to do with either the tumor affecting a pain receptor,
which so how you feel pain is you have pain receptors and you have two different types of pain
receptors. It could either be the cancer affecting that pain receptor, maybe emotion of your body that
moves the cancer to affect that pain receptor or inflammation that's caused that's associated with
the cancer that's affecting that pain receptor. So getting those pains like that that sharp pains
and go have to do with the pain receptor. The weight of Prometheus is heavy on our neck and he
suggestions to minimize the load. Consider using one of those gator things that people
use over their face when they're out fishing and stuff when it's cold morning.
That might give you some support that it's easy to stretch and pull on over that. You know it won't
constrict so much to cause pain and then it's easy to throw in the wash machine and clean.
You could consider it a spandage and just cut it shorter so you can use it to pull up some sort of
scarf I would think would help. It is curging lots of fluid grayish paint and some blood strains.
The smell is very pungent so suggestions to make this more tolerable.
Well you want it to be purged. That's what we want to be happening. The pungent spell is dead cells.
Smaller lump on the neck is starting to impede my vocals against suggestions.
Using your anti-inflammatory nutrition and increasing the anti-inflammatory nutrition is really
the answer to that. If you're using any over-the-counter anti-inflammatory medication,
like Advil or something like that, see if that makes a difference with your vocal chords too
because what Advil is is really an anti-inflammatory. Recently a breast cancer patient asked about
the wisdom of having a pectomy in order to reduce the circulating tumor cells.
That made me wonder if I should be giving a more serious consideration of surgery
as well for the same reason. I haven't put it in off because I did not want to further burn
down my body's system. Now however I year in, I'm 80 pounds lighter and much better place
health-wise. My surgery, however, would be a double mastectomy. I found one using a guide
from Green Smoothie Girl. That's a biological dentist. This person is answering that question
about fighting a biological dentist. Green Smoothie Girl. There are some
Facebook groups out there too that you might be able to consult with biological dentist.
I am not, if you're in a much better place, health-wise, is there a time for getting a mastectomy?
We've had lots of patients do that when they feel like they're kind of stable and better health
getting it removed. They feel better about themselves, feel better about getting the cancer off their
body. Everybody's an individual, so I don't want to push anybody to do that. We have patients that
never even consider that and they're convinced that if they would have done that, they wouldn't be
alive today. So everybody's different, so you really have to be creative on it so that you know
what's best and right for you. Some of my friends take floor 200 milligram ibuprofen three times
a day for a short term joint pain relief. I was thinking maybe I could take curcumin instead or some
other herbal type product. Take ibuprofen and acetaminophen are hard on your liver, so it is an issue
with your liver that you are causing damage and you can't see. So you do need to take that in the
coat. It's like people you can't see the damage to your liver, you don't feel the damage to your
liver, so you know it's hard to, you know, a boy, if I take these, this, it's really helping, you know,
take 800 milligrams ibuprofen three times a day, that's a lot. So yeah, yeah, I would definitely,
I mean, for me personally, I would definitely try curcumin and Boswellia and other anti-inflammatories
you know, in high doses, thinking about trying the liposomal curcumin, that might be better absorbed,
you might have better relief from that, I would try those things for sure. But at a three-day motorcycle
trip, this is the person that was dealing with bone at bone hip pain, I would try the liposomal
curcumin there. How toxic are implants? We're talking about breast implants, they can be very toxic,
even if they don't leak, they can still be toxic. A person can have a sensitivity to the
silicone, they can have a sensitivity to the outer lighting, other chemicals in the outer lighting.
It doesn't mean that everybody's going to have an issue with breast implant, but
they can be a hidden cause of product disease, they can be a hidden cause of autoimmune issues as well.
That's to be that's always going to be, but it certainly can be. I have a few spots on my breast
where the masses are pushing through, any ideas on that. You can do stink topical things on that,
certainly doing different essential oils like frankincens, lemon grass,
on there would be appropriate, you might want to use a carrier oil with it because those can be hot
oils that can irritate the skin, but the closer it gets to the surface, the better you are doing,
so you don't want a breast cancer going deeper towards the chest wall. That's what we don't want.
So when it's moving towards the surface, that's always a very good thing. So keep doing everything
you're doing. I would suggest putting the rife bulb right over that spot, right over the masses.
When you're running your programs, that would be helpful as well. Since I've been on a low animal protein
diet, my thyroid panel is not as good as before, although I am taking the same part of our thyroid.
If this is because of my diet, can I use some kind of amino acids without glutamate, glutamine?
Also, I have found out without certain amino acids, the detox does not happen in the body.
Yes, there's amino acids that you need, those are called essential amino acids.
And then there's also a group of amino acids called not essential amino acids,
because they're not essential for you to consume your diet because your body makes them out of other amino acids.
So remember, glutamate is the amino acid. It actually converts to glutamate through a certain gene sequence
an enzyme that's made through the glute genes. And that glutamate is under a transmitter.
So that's another issue with glutamate. If a person is got a diet for a glutamate, even if they don't
have cancer, and they have defects in that gene, they can convert that glutamate quite quickly.
Glutamate is an excitatory neurotransmitter because OCD, anxiety, ADD, ADHD issues,
and that's a huge problem with young people, with ADD and ADHD.
So it older people typically, anxiety and OCD.
So yes, you know, you could get all your amino acids through plant-based proteins as well.
But, you know, I think this person, we started on some animal proteins.
And lots of times people, you know, I am not a person who thinks everybody should be a vegetarian.
I'm certainly not. And if your cancer is not driven through search and meets, I think you should
be eating them. I think they can really give you a lot of, not just joy, but I think it can
give you a lot of energy. So it's a good source of your B vitamins, and it's sometimes necessary
to help build your blood. How do you determine a breast mass is close enough to the surface to
use black sap? It would be very careful using black sap. You really need to find somebody local
that you could be monitored with if you're going to use black sap. But if you're going to use black
sap on a cancer, it has to be really close to the surface or already broken through the surface.
You know, we've had people do black sap on a tumor that has yet to break through the surface,
but you have to be mentally prepared because the whole idea of black sap is that it's going to
break through the surface. And that's not a pretty site. It's going to be a wound. It's going to be
an open sore. You're going to have to deal with this maybe for months and months and months, maybe
years using multiple black sap applications. You have to be mentally prepared to jump into that
whole realm. So I suggest with people that are thinking about doing that as you go on YouTube and
you search black sap for breast cancer or black sap for a black sap use, you can go to black sap info.com.
They have some videos on there. That's where most people buy their black sap. We don't sell black sap.
But you really do need somebody local that you could have be looking at it and you're going to be
prepared because it's a lot of work, too, because you're feeding the wound twice a day. And you are
having to, you know, dress it twice a day. And it's very difficult. So some with, you know, with
breast cancer, like, I know, I just rather get invested in some people are like, no, I'm not doing that. I
get to say my breast, I'm going to do everything. Again, everybody's in a different place. And that's
a decision that you're going to make, but you got to do your investigation before you put on that path.
Should I be using black sap since I have an open wound and change my blood damage four times a day.
You could certainly investigate that. That's the problem is black sap was really, really creative
for skin cancers. So when you have a skin cancer, the size of a centimeter around. And it isn't
even hardly raised on the skin. That's really what black sap was created for. We start using black
sap on very, very large tumors. It's just, it, that's not really what it, it makes it very difficult.
So do go on black sap info.com. Do investigate it. I'm totally open to, you know, investigation and open
to try new things. I'm open to you doing everything you possibly can. I think that's a recall for,
called to do is be asking God, what, is there anything else I can do? Should I do this?
If, you know, if I was in your position, I certainly might, I don't know. I would be praying
about it and asking God whether that's something I should do. And there are other things if we feel
like we're not going in the right direction that, that we can attempt before back. But I'm totally
open to whatever God's leading you will try to help people in every way that we possibly can.
So, I just want people to know what they're getting into before they do anything. So,
all right, and any other questions? Just saw a cancer webinar that discussed
your biology. What are your thoughts? So, not sure really what the question is. Your
biology is the study of the urinary tract, bladder, ureters, urethra, kidneys. So, don't really
know to be a little more specific on that. Imagine I could perhaps use something else. What would you
recommend? Calling the schedule on a appointment with me. I have to look at what we already have you doing.
But I do want to get your feedback on which direction you feel like you're going, whether you feel like
you're getting better or getting worse. We certainly don't want you to slip down a slippery slope.
Very quickly. So, call a schedule on a appointment with me tomorrow. Okay, please.
And praise the God for you and this guidance. Thank you. Well, thank you and praise the God for
you and I prayed for you. God had me up prayed for all of you guys last night for a long time. So,
I just need to please, if you're going to pray for me, pray that I stay close enough to him that I
can hear him because sometimes I get crazy, busy in this world and I don't listen. And I think when we
don't listen, I know for me, I'll just say it in my personal experience, when I'm not listening to God,
I'm listening to my flesh and I'm listening to the world and you can get, you just don't have that
close relationship with him. But it's like, you just have to slow down and shut up and listen to him
and be obedient to what he's telling you. That takes discipline and that is a work on our
on our part that's all that we have to be diligent with to be obedient to God does require
obedience. You know, our daily verse is perfect for that. Do not be anxious when I think this
will mean we're not going to have anxiety. But it's a reminder that we have anxiety in every
situation we need to have that relationship with him that we're going to hear him in prayer and
prayer. Here it means that that communication with him and petition asking him with an attitude
that thinks, give me, we present our request to God and just my number of hundred requests to him
has got to be Lord, just keep me close to you so that I know that I'm walking in obedience to him
for not discipline be teach me disciple be shaped be mold me to shape me more to the image of your
son. And that is what our purpose here is. All right. I love you guys all of you. We pray in for you
and um um make sure you guys remember that ends Q and A is on Monday too so jump on that as well.
All right. Love you all. Bye bye for now.